all right so a few months ago while in
the throes of insanity i announced that
once we crossed a million views i would
celebrate with an interpretive dance
performed for the sweet baby gang
and the next day having come to my
senses and regain full consciousness i
beg to be relieved of this obligation
and to be released from my promise but
my audience is full of sadists who
demand to see me humiliate myself for
their amusement
and uh so be it um
i am a man of my word
and so as promised and then demanded
i did in fact personally myself
and this is really me 100
i did perform an interpretive dance to
mark this momentous occasion and now we
will show you this piece of art this
work of staggering tragic beauty
where i
personally myself
dance for all of you
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hey
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
well
there it is
uh what is it what just happened
why did it happen
nobody will ever really know for sure
i will say though that uh and this is
just just a little bit of uh if i could
get serious for just a second you know
that through that dance
expressing myself through the movement
of my body in that way
um i can tell you that i felt for the
first time
at home and at peace in the universe i
got in touch with
something deep and primal and raw
i fell in love with with life with
nature
with dance